o dólar hoje foi nosso fazer o exame e
também de fazer o melhor para o time mas
ele está fora do são paulo futebol sabia
bem o que é isso mesmo e pronto
estamos a realizar muitos jovens ainda
estão com 14 chefe da inepar usar o
potencial da companhia em flecha e
levantou e terá contra ninguém
acontece que não é coisa tutorial
então vou descansar e só ele mas vamos
lutar para escolher um dia como colar
rápida para a favela depois de colher um
depoimento na interseção um país
entrosado tem que fazer duas montagens
com mais seguida muscular onde cola no
plano de cessão de uma das faixas e
juntar a outra página falsa impressão
contra a mesa também alinhar vamos
cortar a eternidade como era plantar
o tempo de se entender mais ou menos o
seguinte vai me falar em uma das
extremidades
vamos orientar de precipitação ao longo
do litoral
mas não cola
ainda é só uma vaga de titular no posto
há candidatos e 30 de maio ficou parado
mais ou menos três cêntimos em cola onde
uma família na qual a fazer o mesmo para
o outro lado
agora vamos fazer o ato é só juntar três
políticos e prendê-los com fita crepe
vão ser sempre mais terminar o verão lá
os novos perde força e pronto a fazer
recortes em ver para depois conseguimos
cortar o fio norma vai mobilizar se não
com esse passo
agora vamos incorporar o arco o resto do
corpo
marcar eu largura do ato é só fazer o
espaço saio para que não caia
como é óbvio muscular agora é com vocês
tanto diz ao teu quarto com a nega
leio maio hoje não fica a dor de não
ficar muito grande coisa
enquanto aguardamos por um fio é um
filme na tela mosquiteira gostar de nós
é só pra mim e fala pra ficar tudo bem
fixo
agora fazer o pino ir até o único a
acreditar mas somente convênios a marcar
um livre que ocorre em 90 graus com ela
mas somente 3024 menino do mep mote o
jovem queira dar hipótese com o site e
no final uma passagem colégio
a pesquisa tem claro coloquei dentro de
mais ou menos duas têm 50 da escola e
fazer uma péssima como esta e aquela
parte da frente anti juíza faça no canal
e vamos agora defendeu usando que filme
de costura era então atualizar fio
dental 850 passam mais ou menos uns 10
peixe no final é só dar o nome última
conta do dólar em 5 de abril por sistema
ela vai ter que ela é um mocho guzerá é
crônico e fortificar a besta pode compor
com a sua tela
agora virá contrário rio para outro
pedaço sempre a extremidade dianteira
muito mais pequena que é baixa e 1 face
minimamente
para finalizar a pronúncia por duas
contas col e implantado primeiramente de
1920 nos autos que se está a fazer do
meu lado que é igual a duas unidades mas
me sinto muitas vezes mais e ele vai
ficar no mesmo dia pela pasta por lote
que foi uma péssima mas também de torcer
e fazer meu carro
a mãe de maria e vocês perguntando a
nossa situação está a ficar por aqui já
está bem e pronto para começar o fato de
os comentários do time
juliana foi prometido escreveu que está
bastante estável está obrigado desse
tipo de quadrilha